incredible Legacy of the man who he just
passed a true Titan of this game truly
one of the greatest basketball players
of all time who own this record for
nearly 39 years Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
joins us now
tonight
[Applause]
we are honoring your legacy and what an
incredible Legacy it was uh you're a man
you are very well read and I want to do
a quote from Aristotle which is we are
what we repeatedly do therefore
Excellence is an act not a habit uh not
an act but I have it and I'm
you and LeBron your ability to go for so
long to endure but to also succeed what
did you see in the young man this
evening in his whole career
well LeBron's career is one of uh
someone who planned
to dominate this game he got out of high
school he had the size and the talent to
step right into the NBA and he
immediately started to uh have his
effect and you know it's gone for almost
20 years now so I think that uh you know
you got to give him credit for just the
way that he planned to last and to
dominate and he led his team to uh you
know he led teams to three
World Championships and it wasn't they
didn't get there because of someone else
and LeBron tagged along LeBron LED them
you know he has that uh
indefinable Essence that they call
leadership you know he gets out there on
the court and tries to get things done
guys want to get behind him and see that
that happens because they have that much
respect for him and his talent
yes of course it is
you know it in 1984 when I really
started concentrating on basketball I
think that was a Year you broke the
record but for 84 in high school and
college and my whole professional career
that number has withstand withstood the
test of time in your mind did you ever
think that record would be broken
because I never thought it would be
broken I thought it it had every chance
of being broken uh just that have to
have somebody that the offense focused
on uh continually you know gaming game
out the the offense focused on them
and enable him
or player like myself to accumulate a
whole lot of scoring on
Take Kobe for instance someone that you
played with you know
Kareem you played until you were 42
years old and um
that is incredible when you think about
the longevity aspect an element that
goes into breaking this record so what
advice would you give to LeBron
in extending this you scored almost 7
000 more points after breaking the
records what advice would you give to
LeBron in extending his career and
continuing to to add to this Legacy well
you know I think you should talk to
LeBron about that about you know how he
feels about trying to extend
his career
I I from what I understand he has
another year with the Lakers
so you know he's going to extend this uh
this record even further and be
interesting to see how far it goes
Kareem this is Jamal just want to say
you're one of one we all appreciate you
and thank you for everything you brought
on and off the court thank you because
at a time that you were standing up for
all of us you know it wasn't popular but
you did it do you see any similarities
to how LeBron is using his voice off the
court as well to make good happen in the
community around the world oh yeah
listen what LeBron has done off the
court
is more important than what he's done on
the court you send kids to school he's
provided uh just leadership and an
example of how to live
oh I was very impressed with his family
his mom I met her at Ramos
playoff games in Cleveland and um both
of them LeBron came out and introduced
me to his mom so you know he he really
that's the right values you know family
and uh hard work and all those things
lead to success
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar thank you for
everything you've done to the game for
everything you've done off the court and
for allowing you to to pass along this
torch with so much grace tonight you are
truly a legend and we we honor you thank
you very much sir and I want to hey I
want to tell Shaq
I asked you specifically this evening
because he felt that I was a shame in
you or ignoring you and that would never
be the case and uh you showed him what
what you were all about the way you
crushed all the centers in the league
for a couple of years there so uh I'm on
your side check don't ever let anybody
tell you anything different listen
you're not speaking to me was the best
thing that happened to my career because
all I wanted to do was impress yourself
so I will talk to you soon inshallah and
I love you very much and I will never
ever have beef with the great Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar you ain't got to worry
about that that's back at you I love you
too I want you guys to keep on
impressing the whole world with our game
it's a wonderful game yep I'll talk to
you soon cap thank you Captain